discussion du projet de loi confiance
dans l'action publique au sénat le 11
juillet 2010 cette dernière prise de
parole de catherine tasca en tant que
sénatrice des yvelines
à propos des emplois familiaux des
parlementaires mais il suffirait pour ce
faire d'encadrer strictement ces
embauches familial comme d'ailleurs a su
le faire désormais le sénat en limitant
à un seul emploi ce type de recrutement
et en plafonnant le niveau de
rémunération ses premiers pas dans les
yvelines catherine tasca les faits en
1997 la direction du parti socialiste
l'a choisie comme candidate pour les
élections législatives anticipées dans
la 12e circonscription la campagne
électorale une nouveauté pour la
socialiste
il faut évidemment tenir compte du monde
militant d'abord des adhérents de son
propre parti ensuite de la famille
politique de l'ensemble de la gauche
mais il faut surtout découvrir les
habitants et tenir compte deux parce que
ça c'est l'autre monde et c'est le monde
pour lequel en réalité on est là pour sa
première élection elle est élue députée
face au candidat rpr udf jean michel
fourgous très très heureuse
vous dites une victoire serrée moi je
trouve que par rapport aux précédentes
élections c'est une grande victoire
je suis très heureuse et comme vous le
dites je suis peut-être doublement
heureuse parce que c'est la première
fois que je vis cette émotion
c'est formidable parce que c'est une
victoire partagée et avec beaucoup de
monde
députée elle présidera la commission des
lois elle participe aussi à
l'inauguration du bâtiment vauban de
l'université versailles saint quentin
une cérémonie aux côtés du premier
ministre lionel jospin il nommera
catherine tasca au ministère de la
culture en 2000 un retour aux sources
elle qui a occupé des postes
ministériels à la rue de valois entre
1988 et 1993
cette maison ne m'est pas inconnue j'y
reviens avec un infini plaisir en même
temps croyez moi avec la conscience
aiguë que en quelques années beaucoup de
choses
et je ne siègerait plus dans l'hémicycle
mais je continuerai à me sentir député
des yvelines est en tout cas à à
maintenir un contact très étroit avec la
circonscription lors de l'élection
présidentielle de 2002 catherine tasca
soutien à son tour lionel jospin aux
côtés de jean-paul huchon ou encore de
françois hollande lors d'un meeting
organisé à bois d'arcy le 21 avril 2002
est vécu comme un échec cuisant
[Musique]
quelque chose absolument terrifiant
d'aujourd'hui en 2004 catherine tasca et
élue sénatrice un siège de parlementaire
qu'elle quitte aujourd'hui après 13
années de mandature
c'est un changement qui de fait est
douloureux parce que moi j'ai beaucoup
aimé le sénat est donc là j'ai travaillé
pour les yvelines
pour les yvelines et aussi pour
l'ensemble du pays
mais c'est là que ces faits m'ont
attaches très forte avec les yvelines
entre territoires des yvelines et une
passion pour la culture catherine tasca
met un terme à cette partition politique
sur une note de mozart un compositeur
qu'elle apprécie
[Musique]